[موسيقى]
بجناحين يا طوفان على السماء وشموخ يسرون
يطير الصقر في الاجواء باحثا عن تحدي جديد
سواء كان هجره او فريسه اخرى
الصقر واحد من رموز الثقافه العربيه
الداله على الشموخ والعزه
وفي مصر القديمه كانت للصقر حكايات
واساطير يصل بعضها لحد التقديس هو ابن
الالهين ايزيس وازوريس انه حورس اله العدل
والخير انه الاله حامي ابيه الذي فقد عينه
في معركه اخذ ثار ابيه ثم صار ملكا لكل
مصر
اسطوره تزكي حب البشر واجلاله من الصقور
منذ ابد الدهر وعشق الصقور في مصر والعالم
العربي لم يتوقف عبر الازمان فما بالكثير
من المصريين والعرب ينظرون للصقر في فخار
واعجاب خاصه البدو
البدو يعني عشق الصدور حاجه اكيده متاكده
يعني انهم كلهم
حتى غير الصقار اللي هو برده في طريقه
شغله بس تلاقيه عنده مخصص وقت دائما
[موسيقى]
سافرنا الى احدى صحاري مصر لنعايش
السقارين وهم هو تسقور وذلك اثناء
ممارستهم هويتهم
ولنلتقي من يتركون بيوتهم في ايام طويله
وربما
ممارسه متوارثه بين كثير من العرب حيث
يبدا الاطفال تعلمها منذ الثامنه حتى
يعتاد على الصقور فيالف كل منهما الاخر
اول شهر عشره اكتوبر
[موسيقى]
زي ما الناس تروح تصيف وحاجه اساسيه عندها
احنا عندنا موسم الصيد ده حاجه اساسيه
لازم يطلع الصوت ثلاث شهور خيم في الصحراء
نعمل الاكل على الحطب وكده دي حاجه عندنا
دي حاجه اساسيه بتاعتنا
[موسيقى]
غير ان هذه الهوايه لا تخلو من مخاطر
كبيره قد تؤدي الى ان يفقد الصقر حياته
وهو ما حدث واقعا مع رمضان وابنه
الذين
في الصحراء ولم يجدوا لهم القدام
انا يعني كخبره الصحراء وضرب الصحراء احنا
مرينا بتجربه من فتره قريبه هي كان حصل
معانا حادثه كبيره جدا وتعرض لها ابن عمي
وابنه واخوه صغير كانوا معه في رحله الصيد
وكان المرحوم رمضان هو واخوه مساعد
وابنه شاهين صغير كان معهم في الرحله
رمضان ده كان يمتاز بالخبره خبير في
الصحراء بيضربها بجميع ولكن اساء القدر
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يعني ان هو يعني همم
يحصل معه مخاطر الصحابه وتعرض همم
للتوهان في الصحراء
[موسيقى]
في رمضان الذي احترف السيجاره منذ صغره لم
تشفع له خبته حيث اصر على تتبع صقر دون
استعداد كافر فلم يقدر ما يمكن ان تؤول
اليه الامور في هذه الصحراء التي لا ترحم
احدا طلع منه فجاه طير طير بيحمل ريشه
ريشه تتبع
طير اخذ موجه الريح وصعد ناحيه الرمال
اللي هي المغريه جدا
تفضل وراه تطير فطير فضل صاحبه
فمحبش يسيب الطير وكمل مسيرته وراء الطير
فاااا العربيه زي ما تقول خلصت منه بنزين
على مستوى انه ما يرجعوش اول ما عرف نفسه
الصبح
عرف انه هو مشى في اتجاه عكس اللي هو
انقاذ يعني فتعب منه ابنه شاهين فدي اللي
هي
اثار واتخذ اتجاهه الصحيح في الطريق وعمل
سهم مخلصين ميه كتب وعمل صح في اشاره على
الارض والتاجه في الاتجاه السليم والصح
ولكن ابنه يعني في الصحراء وابنه يعني انت
انت عشت لحظه هو يعتبر ما ثلاث محمد رمضان
مع تقصروا للحاله ان هو ابنه تعب منه فضل
معه بيعنيه
لحد ما لفظ الاخير
بسبع كيلو
اتجاه اللي هو كان ماشي في طريق النجاح
ماشي هو واخوه بعدها اخوه تعب منه
كمان خمسه كيلو بعده
توفوا هم هم الثلاثه
الاثر بتاعو لما سبقوه
وابنه بيمشي ثلاثه كيلو يرجع لهم 5 كيلو 7
كيلو يرجع لهم مش عارف مش عارف يسيبهم
وعايز يشوف اي حد يجي له فيروح مش عاوز
يسيبهم يعني
خلاص بيروح ويرجع
قريب منهم
للسقي مكانه كبيره واهتمام بالغ ومحبه
عظيمه وقدر كبير في قلوب عشاقه الكفر
وخاصه الشعراء الذين تجمعهم به علاقه
ازليه منذ القدم فالصقوا يرمز للرجوله
والشجاعه والشهامه والنخوه والانسان الشام
احرى بان يكون شاب هلا
ويبدا الموسم السنوي للصغار في سبتمبر
وينتهي مع شهر فبراير حيث يجهز الصقارن
الشراك لصيده
من 20/9 بيبتدي تنصيب الحمام بنجيب الحمام
بنعد عليه شروكه اللي هي المخصصه للمصايد
يعني بيجيب حمامه وبحط عليها السلام اللي
هو الشرك بنبتدي نحط الحمامات بعد
المسافات مثلا 300 400 متر من بعض جنب
المخيم
صحراويه كامله
من عند ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
ولان الصقر طائر حاد الذكاء يحتاج اصطياده
تخطيطا من السقار فيتعون الصقر عبر
طريقتين اولهما طريقه الوكريه التي يدعى
فيها الصقر بفريسه تثير لعابه فيضع له
السمان او اليمام او الحمام
فرائسه تعجب الملك في عليائه كي ينقض
عليها وبعد الانقضاض يكون ريش الفريسه في
خيه تقع فيها قدم الصقر
فاحنا نجيبه السمان ده اول نعمل له الشرك
دي عباره عن خيات كده يجي الصقر مسكه اول
ما يبدا ياكل يذبح يذبح الصقر الاول
يتحرك مع الحركه
يعني معظم الطبيعه الجغرافيه بتاعتها
صحراويه
فاعتمدنا على نوعين في الاساس من الطيور
الجارحه هم اللي صار الشاهين وصار الحره
هم يعني اكثر نوعين في الطيور الجارحه
مناسبين للظروف البيئيه اللي عندنا
وللصقور انواع واسماء من بينها صقر
الشاهين والوكري والحر ولكل نوع من الصقور
مكان معيشه ووجهه هجرا وتعد مصر واحده من
اهم معابر الطيور المهاجره التي يستغلها
السقارون المصريون للصيد وبدء ترويض
الصقور واستئناسهم كل طبيعه بتفرض على
الهاوي او الصقار استخدام غير معين
ليه مثلا احنا الطبيعه بتاعتنا الصحراويه
الطبيعه لو في غابات الجماعه في اوروبا
بيستخدموا الباز الباز هو يعني عنده قدره
كبير قوي في المناوره والتحرك بين الاشجار
وبرده الفرائس هناك اكثر همم الارانب
وطاهر همم اسيا في فرائس ثانيه اكبر في
ثعالب في في همم قبائل بتاعه منغوليا
وكذا بتقول بيستخدموا العقبان بقى
والصخر الشاهين له باع طويل بين السقاريين
فهو الاسرع بين اقرانه فجسده واجنحته
القويه تتيح له السفر لمسافه طويله وسرعه
عاليه ونفض شاهين يعني الملكي بالفارسيه
شاهين ما بينزلش على حاجه تعبانه يعني
ممكن يدخل في سرب حمام بيلاقي في واحده
اثنين تعبانين في الارض
من مكانها بسرعه البرق هي دي اللي بيركز
عليها
لانها عرفت تمتاز بصحه جيده
والصقار مدرب المحترف عليم بكيفيه التعامل
مع الصقور كيف يربيه كيف يصطاد الفريسه
وكيف يقطع المسافات
وللصقارين لغه خاصه يتداولون مفرداتها
يوميا كالتدهيل والتلوح
الطير ده بيتمرن على ايه بالضبط
[موسيقى]
بتتعامل معك فيها الظروف اللي انت بتضرب
فيها بتتغير
هواء يوم مشمس يوم ايه نوع الفريسه بيتغير
فانت كل ده بتتعلم اساليب جديده في
التدريب هو اساليب كثيره في الصيد معامله
الترس ذات نفسه والعنايه دي برده بتحتاج
خبره ترقوميه اا بالنسبه ان انت هتبقى
مبتدا هتاخذ جانب نظري هتتعلم نظري اعلمك
السهر ده ايه الانواع ايه الانواع
المناسبه لك ايه هو الادوات اللي بتستخدم
في الهوا دي يعني انت عشان تبدا اللي هو
دي لازم تكون انت محضر ادوات ومكان اللي
تقدر ان انت تراعيه بتطير وتتحكم فيه انا
عشان اتحكم في الطير ده لازم انا عندي
ادوات لازم عند الدرس اللي هو الجوانتي ده
اللي انا لابسه ده عشان يحميني من المخالب
بتاعته طبعا هو المخلب جدا فانت لازم
جوانتي من الجلد الطبيعي عشان يحميك
القيود اللي في رجله دي
دي اسمها الصواريخ الثوابيق المرسل المدور
الحاجات دي كلها الادوات البرقع ده البرقع
ده الانسان اخترع علشان يبدا يتحكم فيه
اللي احنا بنغمي عينيه لكن بنسيبه يقدر
يتنفس ويقدر ياكل برده بس هو مش شايف فهو
لما بيبقى مش شايف بيهدى هو عنده حاسه
النظر دي هي ال ال رقم واحد طبعا الصقر
دائما بيتضرب به المثل في قوه البصر وكده
[موسيقى]
ولابد لي صيد الصقور من عربه دفن رباعيه
تحرك بها السقار متابعنا الصقر الذي يوقع
في الشراك حيث يبقى الصقار مراقبه للصقر
متابع له حتى ينزل مستقرا على الارض
احنا بندخل بالعربيه عشان بيكون الهدوء
طبعا ملزوم من العربيه دائما بتكون
بالدياله الروح الاطمئنان يعني جدا ما
يكونش قلقان منها لكن لو اتعاملنا مشاريع
ورجل وجرينا عليه
بيقلب الطير هنا ممكن ياخذ الصيد ده
بالخيط اللي هو مربوط فيه الصيد وبيطير
فيها لكن في نقطه ثانيه شبكه بنعملها اللي
هي الكفايه جنب المخيم لو احنا ساكتين في
الخيمه نبقى عاملين الشبكه بره الخيمه
كبيره وحاطين جنب منها جميع الانفس للطير
يعني من الحمامه لليمامه للسمانه للعصافير
كل ما يترتب
هويه مليئه بالمغامره والاثاره لذا قد يظن
البعض انه هوايه السيجاره خطره وقد تصيب
الصقار بجرح او نزيف لكن الحقيقه غير ذلك
لان الصقر يحب صقاره ويكون وفيا الله
هواي امنه ما فيهاش اي حاجه خالص
كبيره جدا يعني هو بيقدرك انت بتقدره برده
يعني حاجه بالنسبه لنا احنا حاجه عظيمه
جدا
طبعا
البدوي اخذنا عنك
ودربناه ومرناه وفضل الساره معانا لحد ما
السهر برضه بيبتدي لحد ما يوصل نهايه عمره
لكن لما صعب عده تواجه استقرات في مصر لذا
وجدت بعض الجمعيات القناص المصري لرعايه
الطيور الجارحه لمساعدته وادي السفاره في
ممارسه هوايتهم بكل يسر وسهوله
وهويه السيجاره لم تتوقف عند حد الافراد
الذين يتحركون فرادى دون تنسيق فقد بدات
محاولات الصقارين لجعل الهوايه نشاطا
مؤسسيا يضم المحبين سواء كانوا مبتدئين او
محترفين صغارا او كبارا من البدو او من
غيرهم كان ابرزها جمعيه القناص المصري
التي التقينا عدد من افرادها
هي جمعيه مصريه وانشات 2018
اهدافها هو نشر التراث الصغار سيجاره او
السيجاره
هي تدريب الصقور للصيد بها همم كان زمان
بيعملوا كده عشان بيوفره احتياجاتهم من
اللحوم في في الاماكن في الصحراويه البدو
كانوا بيدربوا الصغور عشان يستظروهم همم
طيور في الموسم الهجره دلوقتي هي بقت
عباره عن تراث همم
كثير قوي من الدول سواء كانت الدول
بيهتم جدا بقت اصبحت الرياضه النهارده همم
هي رياضه الصقور
[موسيقى]
من اهم نشاطات الجمعيه عندنا هي رعايه
الجوارح وخصوصا الطيور اللي بتقع او تتمسك
في وقت الهجره والتوعيه بالطيور والانواع
اللي تنفع لنشاطره في مصر والمخاطر اللي
بتتعرض ليها والانواع اللي ما تنفعش اصلا
للسقاره واللي بتتمسك مع الصيادين او
بتوقع مصابه في اي مكان
الثور طبعا مهمه جدا في البيئه ايه انا عن
نفسي شايف ان تواجد الجوارح في ال- اا في
البيئه هو نوع من انواع الحفاظ على حياه
الانسان لان احنا بنتكلم في ان ربنا خلق
لنا درع طبيعي بيننا وبين الافات وبين كل
الحاجات اللي ممكن تاثر على صحه الانسان
وعلى مصادر غذاءه المشكله همم اللي بيساء
استخدام
الصقور وفي الصيد الجائر للصقور بخلاف ان
مصر موقعها على اتفاقيه سايدس اللي هي
تنظيم تجاره بالحيوانات البريه
[موسيقى]
ويضع الصقرون في مصر الاتفاقيات الدوليه
لحمايه الحيوانات المهدده بالانقراض نصف
اعينهم كما هو الحال مع هذا الصقر الذي
وصل لمصر المصابه من المجر فالتقته الصقار
وعالجه وهاهم يطلقونه مره اخرى ليكمل
رحلته خطوه تظهر محافظه صقار مصر على
الصقور وحمايتها بالنسبه لنا احنا دايما
في تعاون مع وزاره البيئه
احنا
بنبدا بنساعد الوزاره في ان اي طيور
بتتمسك احنا بنحاول ان احنا
خلاص بنشريها من الصيادين طبعا مفيش حد
هيديها لك كده خلينا صادقين مع بعض احنا
بنشتريها من فلوسنا وبنبدا ان احنا نعمل
لها اعاده تاهيل الطيور اللي بينفع انها
تطلق الطيور ما ينفعش انك تطلب يحصل لها
عمليه تبني زي معنا مثلا في اليوتيوب
مش هينفع انها تطلب ثاني انا غير قادر على
التعامل مع البيئه
انما هي المشاكل بتبقى مع الصيدليه
[موسيقى]
طب فزعه محبي الصقور والبدو والذين
انطلقوا بالمئات بحثا عنهم في هذه السحره
الشاسعه حتى وصلوا اليه اخيرا وقد فاضت
روحهم الى بارئها
مباشره
محلي ولكن السيارات اللي كانت معنا غير
كافيه انها همم كانت العربيات كلها عربيات
عاديه فيهم عربيه واثنين دفع رباعي فعمل
نداء همم عبد المولى اخوه الشهيد رمضان
بالفزعه طبعا احنا قبائل بدويه يعني كلمه
الفزع عندنا لها دور كبير جدا
الفزعه يعني النجده
بلا استثناء كل القبائل من كل المحافظات
من محافظه مطروح تواجد في المكان حوالي
400 عربيه سياره دفع رباعي اول يوم توقدوا
حوالي 100 150 عربيه ثاني يوم بقى العدد
بتزايد من محافظات عده ناس بتيجي من الشرق
ومن الغرب كانت البيع للطلب كانت بجميع
طوائف في البدو القبائل تعاطفت مع الموضوع
برده
كل واحد ندي له حقه زي جيشنا برده العظيم
مخابرات المصريه طلعت طيران خاص للبحث
عنهم واا تحركت الطيران على طول وهم اللي
انتم احداثيه برده بالمكان يعني وكان دور
كبير برده وفعال معنا من الجماعه
المشاهدين همم في همم في الموقف كان لقب
لهم دور كبير برده معنا في المساعده فارق
معانا وناس كانت حاضره من كل يعني انا
باقول لك يعني عشنا صعايده وفلاحين والناس
كلهم عاشوا عاشوا معنا اللحظه دي كلها
يعني كلهم يعني بمعنى الكلمه فزعوا
لحد ما وصلنا النقطه كان وصلها جميل جسمي
من قبيله الجواسم
وبلغه بالحداسيه واحد برده ثاني من البدو
وكان معدي هناك وجوده السيارات وصلنا
للعربيه لان العربيه لوحدها فجاه بصينا
لقينا كاتب عمل السهم بطاريه سهم كده على
الارض على الرمال وكاتب مخلصين ماء
كل بعد المسافه بيعمل سهم بقى بعد ما
اتجاهه من كلمه مخلصين ميه بقى بيدي
اشارات لانه رمضان كبره كخبير جدا الصحراء
فيعني كان عاملها سبب من اسباب النجاح همم
ولكن افات المانيه القدر ان هو همم
يعني توفاه الله هذه الحادثه التي تابعها
كل محب الصقور في مصر اثرت عليهم بصوره
كبيره وربما غيرت طريقه تفكيرهم في ملاحقه
الصقور ومتابعتها فمهما يكون ليس للصحراء
كبير
هو كان دائما مخيم بتاعه
اي حد ما عندوش مكان لسه ما عملتش مكان
لسه بيدور على مكان
اولا هو مش من الناس اللي معه فلوس يعني
هو زينا كده عادي
يعني دي اهم صفه فيه ودي من اكثر المواقف
الواحد يعني كلنا كان متاثرين به وعارفين
ان هو قد ايه
على صيده
[موسيقى]
وتقليل السفاره امنيه يرغبها الكثيرون من
الصقارين في مصر خاصه مع امكانيه زياده
الجذب السياحي على غرار دول الخليج وهو ما
يقوله لنا احمد الشريف الذي نظم سباق
للسقور في الصحراء وادي النطرون اطلق عليه
اسم حورس وجاء اليه محب الصقور من مختلف
الاماكن يعني انا اتمنى طبعا الهوايه
هي ترد على البلد بفائده كبيره جدا لان في
عندنا حاجه اسمها السياحه
البيئيه من مشاهده الطيور بقى ل- اا
لاقامه مزارع هنا الاقصار الثور
المستشفيات لرعايه الثور طبعا انت عندك
منطقه الخليج دي همم نمره واحد في العالم
بالنسبه للاقتناء والتدريب الثور بالذات
فهنا طبعا لو اتعملت مزارع على الانكسار
او مستشفيات زائد الموضوع المسابقات
والموضوع اللي همم
ان ان السايح يجي العربي يجي بالسهر بتاعه
هنا في مصر يدخل مصر
يبقى في مسابقه عالميه هنا بتتعمل زي
السباق بتاعنا حورس ده يبقى عالمي سباق
عالمي
[موسيقى]
في ظل اهتمامين بالحياه البريه والحفاظ
على التوازن البيئي واستضافي مصر لقمه
المناخ كوب 22 7 يظل الحلم قائما لدى
الكثير من السقاريين بان تصبح مصر وجهه
الهوايه السيجاره
[موسيقى]